the xbox series x isn't too far off but
if you're an xbox live gold member who
doesn't want to spend more money
good news the free games with gold
lineup for august has been announced
here's what's coming your way first up
on xbox one is portal knights
an action rpg that lets you explore
randomly generated islands
you can choose to play as a warrior mage
or ranger as you craft weapons and fight
monsters with your friends in online
co-op
you can start your adventure anytime in
august as portal nights will be
available all month long
moving from knights to robots xbox one's
other free game is override mech city
brawl
as the name says you take control of a
big mech and battle other bots online
in fact four friends can take control of
a mech together each controlling one of
the robot's limbs voltron style
override will be available from august
16th through september 15th
now don't tune out just yet these 360
games are backwards compatible for you
xbox one players too
the first of these is mx unleashed which
originally released on the first xbox
you can race bikes in story mode or
complete challenges in freestyle mode
using the game's specific controls to
get the best times and scores
the speed of your bike and how your
rider is positioned on it determine how
you ride
mx unleashed will be available from
august 1st through the 15th
last up is red faction 2 another
original xbox game that's being brought
forward
the red faction series is all about
destruction and you'll use a variety of
weapons and vehicles to bring down the
dictator that runs mars
oh yeah this game it's set on the red
planet you can grab it from august 16th
through the 31st
and those are your free games with gold
for august 2020 remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
games with gold lineup every month
[Music]
you